The type of material used on a tennis court can vastly affect gameplay.
Three main types dominate the pro circuit.
Hard courts featured at the Australian and US Open...
...are perfect for an attacking game,...
...courts consist of synthetic or acrylic layers on top of concrete or asphalt.
This creates a rigid uniform surface,...
...which means the ball bounces more predictably than on grass or clay.
Exchanges are fast because little energy is absorbed by the surface,...
...although it can be hard on the knees and ankles, meaning injuries are more likely.
Clay courts as seen at the French Open have a slower surface...
...that produces longer rallies.
The most common form is red clay, made from brick.
The top layer allows players to execute controlled slides,...
...although it's not practical for use in high rainfall areas.
While a quick shower won't interrupt play,...
...clay courts can take a while to dry up after a rainstorm.
Defensive players prefer this surface,...
...which allows players to vary their effects on the ball, particularly topspin.
Grass courts as used at Wimbledon...
...are generally seen as one of the fastest services...
...and favor the serve and volley style of play.
This often produces the shortest matches.
It's a cool and glare-free surface, particularly responsive to slices,...
...although wears out quickly.